[Musique]
et voilà la villardière d'eau qui
maintenant grâce au loto
or un futur radieux gagner au loto
une opportunité immense pour des lieux
en péril de l'histoire française
en lançant le loto du patrimoine
emmanuel macron a fait rêver les
passionnés qui aux quatre coins de
france ont postulé pour porter cette
loterie accompagné d'un jeu de grattage
spéciale de la française des jeux
c'est à stéphane bern que le président a
confié cette mission le 31 mai c'est en
grande pompe à l'elysée qui est
officiellement lancé cette nouveauté
objectif récolter entre 15 et 20
millions d'euros
sur 2000 candidatures 270 sites sont
sélectionnés dont 18 projets phares un
par région administrative
le patrimoine c'est de la culture à
porter demain partout en france et pour
tout le monde
sauver le patrimoine c'est avant tout
une question de volonté collective
mon voeu le plus cher ce que l'on cesse
d'envisager le patrimoine en termes de
coupes budgétaires mais davantage comme
un investissement productif puisqu'il
est avéré qu'il dope l'économie dans les
territoires et qu'il crée de l'emploi
ce loto est une première mais pas une
dernière et que nous allons le répliquer
chaque année et que 1 l'aca blement nous
allons mener ensemble cette ce travail
avec la ministre pour que d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat
il y ait un maximum de projets partout
sur le territoire qui fort de cette
promesse de cette volonté collective et
changer un peu du visage de notre pays
de nos régions de nos villes je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
menacée de péril la villa viardot situé
sur la commune de bougival est l'un de
ces 18 projets phares sélectionnés par
la mission de stéphane bern en piteux
état
on y accède plus que par une porte
dérobée mais pour jorge chaminé baryton
mondialement reconnu l'esprit du lieu ne
demande qu'à ressuscité et nous voilà
dans ses salons de pauline viardot où
elle recevait tout ce que l'europe
compte des musiciens des peintres des
scientifiques des philosophes des
historiens
ils étaient tous là et on construisait
l'europe et donc c'est cet esprit là on
veut faire revivre ici la cantatrice
pauline viardot et son époux louis
recevait notamment alexandre dumas
victor hugo
camille saint saëns gustave flaubert ou
encore de la croix
cette résidence il l'achète en 1874 avec
leur ami ivan tourguéniev immense
écrivain russe qui vivait à leurs côtés
dans une sorte de triangle amoureux
ils aiment tellement beau gerard que les
viardot et tour gagnage vont acheter
cette propriété à parts égales et la
très vite et la datcha tourguéniev surgi
dans le domaine puisque tourguéniev
étaient habitués toujours à vivre avec
les viardot et il a construit la datcha
qui existent la datcha tourgueniev
[Musique]
jorge chaminé rêve de voir revivre ce
lieu pas seulement pour le conserver
mais pour y installer une partie du
centre européen de musique où seront
réunis la villa viardot mais aussi la
maison du compositeur georges bizet
situé à quelques centaines de mètres ici
on l'aimerait réinstaller donc la
musique dans ces lieux est naturellement
faire des conférences des concerts des
masterclass et et faire revivre chose
qu'on a déjà fait pendant de longues
années
mais maintenant le faire revivre dans
dans cette ville a enfin restaurée
[Musique]
oh
on
quand je suis rentré dans ses salons et
j'étais mûr là je me suis dit comment ça
se fait que la france qui possède ici un
des hauts lieux du patrimoine musical du
19e siècle
elle est blessée cette maison à
l'abandon depuis 18 ans en france comme
en europe
jorge chaminé ne cesse de porter son
projet allant jusqu à le présenter à
l'elysée lors d'un déjeuner avec le
couple présidentiel a expliqué que la
musique était véritablement la racine
est la source de ce projet mais qu'elles
avaient toutes ses ramifications social
économique touristique également dans
ses dialogues avec les arts avec les va
être avec les sciences et donc il a très
bien compris il a il m'a il m'a beaucoup
touché parce qu'il avait une feuille
blanche devant lui et et dès que je
répondais à ces questions il prenait des
notes et à la fin de ce déjeuner il a
dit il faut faire quelque chose
une autre personnalité suit de près le
destin de la villa viardot plus encore
des travaux côte alain schmitz et
sénateur des yvelines mais aussi délégué
ile de france de la fondation du
patrimoine qui a piloté la sélection des
sites à sauver aujourd'hui il est venu
s'enquérir du futur de la villa viardot
alors qu'est ce que vous espérez en
termes d' enveloppe et surtout quel est
le montant des travaux
j'allais dire uniquement pour sauver
déjà le bâtiment ou maïs tumeur avec
l'architecte du patrimoine
deux millions cinq cent mille 3 millions
d'euros grâce au loto on estime qu'on
aura déjà six cent mille euros
j'espère que ça va monter ou si avec la
participation des français à ceux à
cette opération
quelles sont toutes à la fois le
calendrier et la nature des travaux qui
pourront être réalisés écoutez une très
vite j'espère puisque je pense qu'un
hiver de plus ce serait catastrophique
pour cette maison donc très vite il va
falloir s'assurer des fondations il de
la toiture naturellement et de tous les
travaux qui ceux qui vont être
nécessaires notamment pour pour
raffermir ses façades qui aujourd'hui
notamment les friches commence à être
périlleusement dans un état de chutes on
voit évidemment qu'il ya eu un chauffage
avec des conduites donc je pense qu'il
ya des travaux de gros oeuvre est très
conséquent absolument des travaux
conséquents il ya il ya naturellement
voit pas tant la dégradation de ses murs
il y avait des grosses taches d'humilité
aussi et qui s'infiltrent petit à petit
dans c dans cette fresque c'est surtout
surtout vous voyez là il ya eu des
dégâts des eaux
le pire le pire se trouve au premier
étage le pire car au premier étage où se
trouvaient les chambres on s'aperçoit de
l'étendue des travaux à effectuer
monsieur le sénateur regarder le piteux
état de cette corniche qui commence
absolument et toutes les décors en stuc
et tomber les décors intérieurs et andé
pour le sénateur ce loto du patrimoine
est une merveilleuse idée qui va
permettre d'impliquer encore davantage
les français dont le soutien au
patrimoine du pays
il n'y a pas de désengagement de l'état
en contrepartie jaillir d'un engagement
citoyen non je crois que les deux sont
parallèles ces deux fronts l'état
continue à assumer les charges
régaliennes qui sont les siennes
notamment les grands châteaux
historiques les cathédrales mais en
parallèle il est important de lancer une
action de sensibilisation le message de
l'état c'est de dire 'nous continuons
notre notre soutien au patrimoine nous
le pérennisons c'est ce qu'a dit le
président de la république
durant les cinq années de son mandat en
revanche seuls l'état ne peut pas tout
faire donc nous avons besoin d'être aidé
[Musique]
réfléchir à diversifier les sources de
financement
c'est tout l'objet d'une mission
d'information sénatoriale sur le mécénat
culturel alain schmitz en est le
rapporteur et aux côtés de la présidente
de la mission maryvonne blondin
il reçoit ce jour là la directrice
générale de la fondation du patrimoine
[Musique]
sachant que la fondation du patrimoine
était le bras armé en quelque sorte de
cette mission berne il était important
d'avoir votre non seulement votre avis
la façon dont vous voyez l'évolution
possible de semer ces deux là même si
j'ai dû très attentivement la la note
que m'avait nous avions adressé
aujourd'hui cette ressource publique
elle devient minoritaire dans notre
budget l'essentiel étant fourni par du
mécénat la peau du mécénat l'entreprise
et du mécénat populaire
la fondation a un budget d'environ 30
millions d'euros cette année et
aujourd'hui ce que ces 30 noms à dont 20
qui viennent pour la fondation du
patrimoine
le loto est une nouvelle manière de
poursuivre sa mission qui est de
collecter de l'argent auprès de mécènes
une ressource toujours plus importante
et qui reste à développer
on a une croissance très forte du
mécénat populaire ces dernières années
on a fait plus 50 % sur le mécénat
populaire
on a aussi la conviction qu'on peut
démultiplier le mécénat des entreprises
notamment des petites entreprises sur le
patrimoine
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un attachement
au territoire qui est important et puis
aujourd'hui on tape de responsabilité
sociale
toutes les entreprises savent bien qu'il
faut aider la france des territoires
pour la loterie de cette année la
fondation du patrimoine qui a piloté la
sélection avec stéphane bern a veillé à
cette représentation des territoires
avec 18 sites vitrines sélectionner un
par région
des lieux très variés comme forcing
ognes représentant la bretagne
ancien site militaire occupant une île
et qui va bénéficier de 162 milles euros
pour accueillir l'école de voile des
glénans
en région auvergne rhône-alpes c'est là
que du bouvier qui empochera 177 mille
euros pour sauver ce témoignage menacé
de l'époque romaine en normandie le
château de carnot ville rongée par le
mérule un champignon dévastateur
touchera près de 500000 euros pour être
restaurées et l'outre-mer n'est pas
oubliée chacune de ces cinq régions
étant représentés pour la martinique
c'est la maison d'aimé césaire qui a été
choisi les cent mille euros du loto du
patrimoine qui lui seront consacrés
doivent contribuer à sa rénovation pour
une ouverture au public
[Musique]
dix-huit grands gagnants pour cette
première édition un choix important pour
jean pierre leleux considéré comme le
monsieur patrimoine du sénat je crois
pouvoir dire que le jury autour de
stéphane bern qui a sélectionné ses
débuts projet a voulu pour une première
fois démontré que notre patrimoine était
très diversifiée qu'il n'y avait pas que
les châteaux qu'il y avait aussi
d'autres éléments patrimoniaux qui sont
forts et que toutes les candidatures
étaient possibles c'est ce qui c'est ce
soit est assez symbolique en réalité
pour dynamiser une demande dans les
années à venir
demande qui ne sera pas forcément
satisfaite on le sait mais qui fait
bouger les choses et ça je crois que
c'est bien
[Musique]
chaque semaine ou presque
direction le ministère de la culture où
le sénateur préside la commission
nationale du patrimoine et de
l'architecturé une instance qui fournit
des avis à la ministre pour décider des
sites qui seront classés monuments
historiques ou encore valider des
travaux sur ce patrimoine classe nous
avons au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale tenu à ce que ce soit un élu
qui préside cette commission ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant en tout cas en
ce qui concerne la commission nationale
des monuments historiques
pourquoi parce que bon je ne veux pas
dire que l'administration n'est pas à
même de présider une telle commission
mais l'élu porte un autre regard
c'est lui qui est confronté sur le
terrain à des remontées d'informations
que peut-être l'administration ne
ressens pas de la même manière
les avis de la commission sont seulement
consultatifs mais suivie à 95% par le
ministère dans cette commission
il y à des architectes des représentants
d'associations des élus locaux
un large panel pour pouvoir représenter
tous les acteurs du patrimoine
aujourd'hui c'est sur l'orientation des
travaux du château de villers-cotterêts
dans l'aisne que la commission doit se
prononcer un chantier souhaité par
emmanuel macron cette étude a été
réalisée dans le cadre du projet
présidentiel de confier au centre des
monuments nationaux la gestion du
monument afin de le réhabiliter de
l'ouvrir au public après des années de
déshérence et d'y installer un centre
dédié à la francophonie
pendant plus d'une heure l'architecte en
chef des monuments historiques présent
son étude et souhaite notamment
privilégié l'état du château du xviiie
siècle
quitte pour cela à détruire une partie
des ajouts postérieurs
un choix dont la commission va vivement
débattre on va aborder la séquence
questions-réponses donc on est dans le
stade et précision que les membres de la
commission pourrait demander à toutes
les personnes qui ont fait qu'ils ont
exposé présenté les orientations pour le
château le principe en fait de
privilégier les tags 18e paul baron et
moi même on est quand même un petit peu
ennuyé par cette approche qui nous
sommes un peu réductrice
parce que l'histoire complexe de villers
cotterêts demeure royale puis matière et
défaut de mendicité après la révolution
second faut pour nous avec ce qu'on
appelle la grande histoire nationale
je suis heureux de voir tout ce qui se
passe et je l'aimerai qu on ne jette pas
tout de suite les éléments du 19e siècle
on en aura besoin
et ils font partie profondément du
monument je pense qu'il a peu prématuré
de dire aujourd'hui on va raser tel
bâtiment tel bâtiment tel bâtiment
tant qu'on ne connaît pas les principes
fonctionnel sur lequel s'articule le
projet présidentiel
à l'issue de ces débats c'est à huis
clos que la commission présidée par jean
pierre leleux se concertent pour rendre
un avis
un exercice difficile pour ceux qui
défendent leur projet mais nécessaires
pour veiller à la conservation du
patrimoine
de toute manière on peut pas faire ce
qu'on veut le principe c'est que le
monument historique et monuments
historiques parce qu'il a déclarée
d'intérêt public donc c'est quel que
soit l'objet principal c'est la
conservation donc l'aménagement vient en
général après la conservation comme très
rarement à d'autres lieux où on se pose
pas la question en ces termes et on a
fait tous l'objet c'est d'arriver à
concilier les deux c'est à dire faire en
sorte que les contraintes soient bien
connue bien intégrés et qu'elle ne
devienne pas un problème pour le projet
d'aménagement et quand c'est bien
conduit ça marche ou pas tu la vis sur
villers cotterêts sera favorable avec
quelques recommandations
le projet de rénovation peut désormais
être lancée
mais jean pierre leleux est bien
conscient que tous les projets n'ont pas
la chance d'être choisis par le chef de
l'état ou de gagner au loto et que c'est
parfois la seule volonté de particuliers
qui porte le patrimoine oublié
on peut comprendre qu'on ne pourra pas
réhabiliter ou sauvegardés totalement
tous les édifices qui en manifestent le
besoin
donc c'est vrai que quand il y à dudu
des associations du monde associatif qui
s'engagent en valorisant au delà de
l'argent au delà des financements
eux-mêmes nécessaire mais par
l'artisanat par la mise à disposition de
bénévoles de savoir faire c'est
extrêmement réconfortant de voir ça ça
veut dire que il ya une concrétisation
des amoureux du patrimoine qui passent
leur temps bénévole à reconstruire et
réhabiliter un certain nombre de lieux
je rends hommage à tout ce monde
associatif
[Musique]
des sites exceptionnels porté par des
passionnés il y en a des milliers sur le
territoire français au coeur de
l'aveyron surplombant la ville
d'espalion
il y a par exemple le château de
calmont-d'olt
[Musique]
et du haut du donjon que le propriétaire
et ses équipes ont reconstruit la vue
sur les environs est à couper le souffle
alors là on découvre le panorama
c'est absolument gigantesque on a les
monts d'aubrac sur notre gauche avec un
plateau basaltique donc la faille de la
vallée du lot et l'autre côté les
causses calcaires
c'est une vallée qui offre des
contrastes saisissants
[Musique]
thierry plume a acheté le site en 1986
ce passionné d'histoire et de vieilles
pierres s'est engagé pour remettre en
valeur ce château dont la construction
date du 11e siècle
une passion née chez lui dès le plus
jeune âge mon oncle qui était décorateur
à l'opéra comique m'a fabriqué pour noël
un château mais un château de rêve
j'avais 6 ans et on m'a offert fall père
noël m'a offert donc un château et qu'un
pont le vix qui se remonte est avec tous
les détails les mâchicoulis tout ça et
ça a certainement alimenter énormément
mon imagination de jeunes enfants et
donc ensuite j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps à arpenter les châteaux les ruines
parce que j'avais cette sensibilité et
me trouvant ensuite par les hasards de
la vie être artisan juste au pied de
calmont-d'olt et bien les choses sont
apparues ainsi et ce sont des coulées
jusqu'à l'achat de cet ensemble de
ruines recouvertes de végétation en 1986
sans fortune personnelle
ils achètent donc le site en empruntant
180 mille francs soit moins de 30000
euros et avec ses amis commencent à
faire revivre les lieux d'abord en
s'attaquant à la végétation qui avait
repris ses droits sur le site jusqu à le
masquer dès les premiers mois de
bûcheronnage légende l'environnement les
espalionnais pensait que on avait déjà
remonté une partie du château non on
avait juste enlevé l'écran qui le masqué
jusqu'à ce jour là alors c'est un tas de
cailloux et on a commencé dès la
première année à faire du bûcheronnage
des fouilles archéologiques
et puis quand on dégage un mur si on le
stabilise pas immédiatement
celui-ci ce détruits donc on a mis en
oeuvre tout un procès ce qui était celui
avec nos référents la drac les services
de l'archéologie de faire du dégagement
stabilisation dégagement stabilisation
le château était classé en 92 l'état a
reconnu son intérêt historique son
intérêt architectural un classement
registre des monuments historiques qui
sonne comme une reconnaissance de l'état
mais ne fait pas pour autant revivre le
lieu l'association ne reçoit que 10000
euros par an de subventions dont 4000
euros de l'état le département et la
région
complétant ce maigre pécule bien sûr que
thierry plume aimerait davantage
c'est pour cela qu'il a candidaté au
loto du patrimoine mais le château de
calmont-d'olt ne fait pas partie des
heureux élus
ce sont donc les 20000 visiteurs annuels
qui contribue à 90% à financer le lieu
nous avons des animations alors le côté
animation ça paraît un petit peu
superflu pas du tout c'est ce qui génère
les entrées sur le site et qui permet de
financer les travaux de restauration
c'est une association aujourd'hui qui
gère le site elle est totalement
autonome avec 150000 euros de budget
annuel l'association est loin d'avoir
gagné au loto
alors pour effectuer les travaux ce sont
d'autres passionnés bénévoles qui
s'inscrivent chaque année et qui
permettent de re construire pas à pas le
château de calmont-d'olt ce matin la
responsable de ces chantiers de
bénévoles
c'est audrey le court elle encadre les
volontaires présents pour cette session
taille de pierre reconstitution de tours
avec archère la fierté de voir avancer
le chantier est une formidable
récompense donc la tour nord enfin
terminé on peut vraiment marquer la
différence entre ce qui restait
l'existant et ce que nous on a remonté
toute la partie qui est jointe et en
blanc la transition est assez évidente
ça c'est tout ce que l'association a
remonté
aujourd'hui c'est déchargement de pierre
qui seront ensuite taillé pour remonter
les murs de l'enceinte
les chantiers de bénévoles une
expérience humaine incomparable pour
tous ceux qui y participent
forcément c'est pas des professionnels
près c'est tout l'intérêt de ces
chantiers de bénévoles c'est devenir
d'acquérir des compétences et là du coup
le principe de restauration prend une
autre dimension
dimensions des changes de partage c'est
des gens qui viennent sur leurs vacances
ils pourraient être sur des transats au
bord de la plage banon l'a aujourd'hui
sont là à portée des grosses pierres et
donc c'est surtout voilà cette dimension
des changes humain qui va avoir lieu
la constitution de ce groupe de gens qui
se connaissent pas entre eux qui
viennent de divers pays n'ont pas
forcément le même âge qui viennent pas
des mêmes milieux sociaux qui vont se
retrouver vraiment a partagé pendant
deux semaines à cette vie commune des
pierres qu'il faut retail et avec
précision
comme à l'époque de l'édification du
château là encore ce sont les bénévoles
qui s'attelle à cette tâche
après avoir été formé bonjour tout le
monde
llodra va très bien on s'avance ce pied
d'art cher d'accord d'accord
pierre trois pieds tu peux on peut la
soulever voir un peu le tua la
silhouette de la canonnière dessus
ouais ouais ouais tu as effectivement je
te fais confiance
bravo je ne travaille me spa bouge pas
le chantier du mois de juin touche à sa
fin l'heure de partager le bilan de ses
travaux
comme chaque année pour célébrer la
saint jean
thierry plume convie les habitants des
environs les membres de l'association et
tous les curieux qui le souhaitent à
venir partager un moment festif sur les
hauteurs d'espagne avec thierry plume on
reprend son rôle préféré celui de
compteur de l'histoire des châteaux qui
a notamment été témoin de la guerre de
cent ans qui a fait rage dans l'aveyron
au 14e siècle
le rouergue en 1360 va passer aux mains
des anglais parce qu'on va le donner en
dotation aux anglais pour libérer le roi
de france entre autres un tiers du
territoire français et il va rester
anglais pendant neuf ans et c'est après
la reprise du territoire par les
français que cette enceinte va être
édifié alors comment on le sait il n'ya
pas d'art shiv en connaît rien du tout
seulement vous le verrez tout à l'heure
si on se met devant une archère et quand
se place devant avec un arc anglais qui
mesurent la hauteur de son utilisateur à
peu près 1 m 70 l'arc ne tient pas c'est
fait pour des arcs français qui mesurait
un médecin quand il ya du vent attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la loterie organisée le 14 2 septembre à
la veille des journées du patrimoine
amènera à cette grande cause nationale
un coup de projecteur bienvenu car
sélectionnés ou non pour cet événement
le patrimoine français a besoin d'un
nouvel élan pour perdurer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]